OK.
Very exciting.
We have increased the duration of The Daily
Show by 10 percent.
Now, this just might not sound like some big
victory, but a year ago we increased the duration
of the show 10 percent.
We've done it again.
The way we've done this is by cutting the
amount of breaks from the broadcast show we
have this hour show on radio TV.
It can't go longer than an hour.
There were commercial radio shows that in
an hour have thirty eight minutes of content
that used to be us.
We've expanded, expanded, expanded, expanded.
We've now added another 10 percent to the
show, making it nearly a full hour show.
And that is fantastic.
You might have noticed this week that we're
able to look at some stories in more depth.
We're not going to cram more into the show.
It's just going to let us do more depth for
the shows, for the stories that we're already
doing.
I think it's a really great thing.
We are also adding a daily written digest
of the show.
A lot of people have written to me and said,
you know, David, I prefer to read stuff.
I like your perspectives.
I like the show.
But it's easier for me to read on the subway.
Imagine when people took the subway to work
in those days.
I like reading on the subway or whatever.
We are going to be turning our daily newsletter
into.
A sort of written digest of the show.
You can sign up for what will become this
in the next couple of weeks on my Web site
at David Pakman dot com, just sign up for
the newsletter.
You'll get all of it.
It's all great stuff.
You can also sign up for that at David Pakman
dot sub stack dot com.
It will also provide a new way to support
the show, but it's also going to be free for
everybody that wants it for free.
Really, really great stuff.
I am thinking of this virus phase for the
show.
I am thinking of it as the process of a caterpillar
becoming a butterfly.
OK.
I use this analogy on the bonus show yesterday.
We were a caterpillar going into Corona virus
during Corona virus.
We are in the chrysalis stage.
I'm going back to like third grade science
class.
We are now in the chrysalis stage.
And my goal is that we will come out of Corona
virus reemerging as a butterfly, less orange,
of course, than a monarch.
I don't want to be like Donald Trump, but
as a butterfly with a lot of great things
and a better program and all of these things.
So exciting stuff and very, very good news.
Looking forward to all of it.
Once we get past this difficult time